can i ask you
for advice to me and to others
about what's the take to build a
successful startup
oh i don't know i haven't done that talk
to someone who did that
well you know
uh this is like another book of years
that i'll buy for 67
i suppose so there's
one of these days will sell out yeah
that's right jailbreaks are going to be
a dollar and books are going to be 67.
how i uh how i joe broke the iphone by
george cotts that's right
how i jailbroke the iphone and you can
too
in 21 days that's right that's right oh
god
okay i can't wait but quite so you
haven't introspected
you have built a very unique
company i mean not not you but you and
others
but i don't know um there's no
there's nothing you have an interest but
you haven't really sat down and thought
about like
well like if you and i we're having a
bunch of we're having some beers
and you're seeing that i'm depressed and
whatever i'm struggling
there's no advice you can give oh i mean
more beer more beer
yeah i think it's all very like
situation dependent
um here's okay if i can give a generic
piece of advice it's the technology
always wins
the better technology always wins and
lying always loses
build technology and don't lie
i'm with you i agree very much the long
run long run sure that's the long run
you know what the market can remain
irrational longer than you can remain
solvent
true fact well this is this is an
interesting point because i
ethically and just as a human believe
that um
like sm like hype and smoke and mirrors
is not at any stage of the company is a
good strategy
i mean there's some like you know pr
magic kind of like
you know you want a new product yeah if
there's a call to action
if there's like a call to action like
buy my new gpu look at it it takes up
three slots and it's this big it's huge
buy my g for you yeah that's great if
you look at
you know especially in that in the ai
space broadly but
autonomous vehicles like you can raise a
huge amount of money
on nothing and the question to me is
like i'm against that
i'll never be part of that i don't think
i hope not
willingly not but like is there
something to be said
to uh essentially lying
to raise money like fake it till you
make it kind of thing
i mean this is billy mcfarland the fire
festival like we all we all
experienced uh you know what happens
with that no
no don't fake it till you make it be
honest
and hope you make it the whole way the
technology wins
right the technology wins and like there
is i'm not
yeah you just like the anti-hype you
know that's that's lava kps reference
but
um hype isn't necessarily bad
i loved camping out for the iphones
um you know and as long as the hype is
backed by
like substance as long as it's backed by
something i can actually
buy and like it's real then hype is
great and it's a great
feeling it's when the hype is backed by
lies that it's a bad feeling
i mean a lot of people call elon musk a
fraud how could he be a fraud
i've noticed this this kind of
interesting effect which is
he does tend to over promise
and deliver what's the better way to
phrase it
promise a timeline that he doesn't
deliver on he delivers
much later on what do you think about
that because
i do that i think that's the programmer
thing too
i do that as well you think that's a
really bad thing to do or
is that okay well i think that's again
as long as like
you're working toward it and you're
gonna deliver on it
it's not too far off right
right like like you know the whole the
whole
autonomous vehicle thing it's like i
mean i still think
tesla's on track to to beat us i still
think even with their even with their
missteps they have
advantages we don't have um you know
elon is better than me at at like
marshalling massive amounts of resources
so you know i still think given the fact
they're maybe making some wrong
decisions
they'll end up winning and like
it's fine to hype it if you're actually
gonna win
right like if elon says look we're gonna
be landing rockets back on earth in a
year and it takes four
like you know he landed a rocket back on
earth
and he was working toward it the whole
time i think there's some amount of like
i think when it becomes wrong is if you
know you're not going to meet that
deadline
if you're lying yeah that's brilliantly
put like
this is what people don't understand i
think
like elon believes everything he says he
does
as far as i can tell he does and i i
detected that
in myself too like if i it's only
if you're like conscious of
yourself lying
yeah i think so yeah now you can't take
that to such an extreme
right like in a way i think maybe billy
mcfarland believed everything he said
too right that's how you start a cult
and everybody uh
kills themselves yeah yeah like it's you
need you need
if there's like some factor on it it's
fine and you need some people to like
you know keep you in check but like
if you deliver on most of the things you
say and just the timelines are off
yeah it does piss people off though i
wonder
but who cares in the long arc of history
the people
everybody gets pissed off at the people
who succeed
you